peu
[Musique]
c'est en état je vais poser des
questions qu'on d'accord la punition
préféré qu est ce que tu préfères est
pincé mort du piquet j'aimerais mieux
mordu instinct érotique ce truc là il me
semble que c'est plus douloureux est
plus agréable en même temps maintenant
je vais te demander de creuser un peu ta
mémoire le mot le plus con en amour
c'est merci encore
oui oui dans l'ordre se seraient encore
ensuite merci bonté coincés dans un
ascenseur est ce que tu préfères être en
compagnie de bhl et pda ou vge qui s'est
vu
valéry giscard d'estaing idiote je peux
pas être tout seul tu as une amie qui
arrivent à l'improviste chez toi et
qu'est ce qui te gênerait le plus
d'avoir sur ta table de nuit
un godemichet ou mein kampf mannequin pl
et bien moi ce serait le godemichet
voiture et a choisi reste que tu
préférerais faire l'amour avec un mec
très laid ou avec une jolie si un mec
très pas très curieuse alors à qui tu
trouves tu le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles je ne
sais pas porter de jugement je crois que
l'un et l'autre doivent avoir une bonne
raison
tolérante penses tu que pour réussir il
failli être [ __ ] tueuse ou
calculatrice
je crois pour réussir vraiment bien il
faut être ni l'une ni l'autre tu es donc
très ambitieuse la bombe fatale arrive
dans cinq minutes
tu fais quoi je regarde par la fenêtre
salez ça nous montre qu'il boycotte
depuis qu'on 53 54 et tout de suite on
m'avait moi j'étais à la
comédie-française à un sérieux et tout
est la première chose qu'on me dit on
diffame nea maillot de bain j'étais
absolument horrifiés en plus je me
trouvais épouvantable et dès que je suis
sorti du train à l'époque on y allait en
train le fameux prince bleu après une
nuit complètement dingue où tout le
monde rit bois etc
on a foutu en maillot de bain et on m'a
mise au bord de la mer en général tout
ça mais cannes c'est jamais très beau
alors un temps gris la mer froide oblige
à défendre des causes qui ne vont pas du
tout comme un tablier à une vague alors
que les filles qui sont les nôtres
le petite starlette pas méchant qu'ils
font bien moi je sais pas faire ça
devient petit maillot à pois
j'avais en ayant un point que j'avais
acheté chez givenchy bozilo alors vous
connaissez la terre entière et je
voulais faire une interview vous dire
que je vais vous citer les noms de jean
ah oui c'est terrible ça mais pas vous
fâcher une autre en pagne c'est nous qui
gagnons à vous écouter
alors je vous citer des noms de gens et
vous réagissez par exemple louis malle
vous l'avez beaucoup aimé vous l'aimez
toujours touchant vous croyez que vous
était d'abord un ascenseur pour
l'échafaud avait-on les à main et les
amants et derna fidesz notre film
ensuite on va en parler mais est ce que
vous auriez fait les amants si vous
n'aviez pas été excusez-moi amont avec
lui quand même très est en train dit où
vous l'auriez pas fait vous l'auriez
fait ben n'aurait pas été possible sans
lui et sans moi après vous avez fait
viva maria et la huent un peu des
problèmes parce que peut le dire
maintenant la prescription bardot quand
même
c'est un peu chier quoi sinon il n'y a
pas vraiment eu l'angle m c'est vrai
qu'elle était un peu chiant ouais mais
c'est elle et qu en tout cas par mois
tout à fait bien entendu oui oui mais
parce qu'il y avait tous ces
journalistes tous ces photographes
autour et ce qui comptait pour les
médias c'était la rivalité s'était alors
que rivalité il n'avait absolument pas
mais quelquefois c'était emmerdant
datant du 8 heures une chaleur de plomb
c'était pas toujours alors je lui
demandais de me prévenir quand même ce
rêve-là mais c'est difficile non plus il
s'occupait plus de lui parce qu'avec
vous il savait que c'était réglé un peu
donc eu de la tension
non non il ne faisait parce qu'il a la
santé beaucoup plus fragile il la santé
beaucoup plus fragile c'est vrai que
quelquefois je ne connais pas très bien
de sa part à lui orson welles voulait
que du rock est venu à g koné je
débutais presque gelé connu à la comédie
française
ça devait être en 1951 est gelée suivi
toute sa vie tu te montres l'époque il a
jamais été très mince il était il était
bel homme et puis j'ai jamais pensé à sa
corpulence
après je me suis pas inquiété un petit
peu inquiété mais c'était à cause de sa
fragilité de la santé
et lorsque je me sentais malheureux mais
j'ai toujours trouvé beau c'est vrai
qu'il n'aimait pas qu'on le voit mon jeu
non il n'est pas sûr qu'un jour le v
surpris en 9 tonnes entre un bon jeu oui
on avait changé le widi un cochon de
lait entier qu'il avait devant lui on
m'avait donné une adresse à côté de
madrid et j'y suis allé avec un ami il y
avait personne et on nous a proposé
différentes salles
une sorte d'auberge et puis j'ai ouvert
une porte et or ce n'était là j'ai vu
qu'il était furieux j'ai fait comme si
je ne l'avais pas vu et un jour vous a
proposé de tout quitter pour le suivre
aux états unis vous êtes papa tout
quitter ils voulaient payer le dédit de
la comédie française
bunuel c'est un homme que j'aurais pu
amener falm ans il avait été un peu plus
jeunes ont marqué son ménage mais je
n'ai pas mais ça me gênait lui alors je
dis lui disais que j'aurais aimé qu'ils
soient mon père et lui me disait que
j'avais tort parce qu'il aurait été
absolument tyrannie qui nous restera
enfermé dans un placard
ils nous auraient pas le père du cinéma
non c'est enfin un peu comme votre peur
oui même en perdre pour nos 13 ans
étoile excité mais gallas il serait
devenu elle vous raconter ça qui quand
tu étais petit bolide qu'il était
sensible mais pas sentimental
oui c'est très sympa retrouvés et que
quand ils étaient petits pendant qu'ils
travaillent y mettait du sparadrap sur
la bouche de sauf quand il était petit
quant à vente et grands à bon droit
quand il monte grand candy travaillait
avec jean claude carrière effet mettez
du sparadrap sur la bouche de ça ça
parce qu'elle était trop bas alors vous
travaillez dans nikita avec besson vous
avez passé peuvent signer par sa
recherche du bras de ses plus farouches
recherche du bras ouais mais parce qu'il
est obsédé comme tous les hommes dont
nous avons parlé mais peut-être d'une
façon parce qu'il est plus jeune et
qu'il appartient à cette époque dans
laquelle nous vivons
ça n'est pas détourner ni par la
littérature ni par un art plastique
c'est cinéma cinéma cinémas et
quand nous avons travaillé ensemble j'ai
tourné quoi quinze jours dans les kits à
je me suis amusé parce qu'ils
s'amusaient absolument follement il
faisait refaire les seins tu peux me
faire un peu comme ça ah pis si on
essayait comme ça un peu plus triste un
peu plus des plus lent plus rapide on
sentait que ça pouvait durer durer vous
pardonner tous au réalisateur
vous appelez ça des particularités pour
pas dire des défauts oui oui y'a pas il
n'ya pas des fonds alors j'ai suivi
pendant un mois j'étais tellement en
extase béate qui m'est arrivé d'oublier
mon texte
c'est embêtant oui et puis surtout dans
le prince et hambourg avoir un trou dans
la salle dans la cour du palais des
papes s'est mis à le vendre parce gobain
bleus tournaient avec le gamin oui mais
moi j'aime tous les hommes avec lesquels
je travaillais oui dans le grisbi
oui dont le vieux et puis j'ai fait un
film alors la suite ah j'oubliais le
titre oubliée non pas du tout ce qui
l'était catcheur lino ventura oui je
sais
est ce que vous êtes riche
non je vais rien vous avez quoi j'ai pas
grand chose je vis avec ce que je gagne
ou sur le chemin quand vous avez vendu
votre propriété du prix burgos remake 7
hectares quand même j'aime bien toucher
de l'argent mais j'avais des dettes
je venais de divorcer et contrairement à
ce qu'on pense un immense américain ça
peut coûter cher selon selma pas
rapporter des sous du tout contraire et
dans ces moments là quand j ai vraiment
besoin d'argent
est ce que vous avez pensé à faire la
publicité non non j'ai fait des
émissions de radio radio monte car je
vais raconter la vie destin je voyageais
beaucoup c'était assez étonnant
d'ailleurs c'était une période où
j'avais pas un rond j'ai même pas de
quoi prendre un taxi
j'ai pas tellement intense et 1,80 et
j'étais invité partout alors on faisait
un hommage à jeanne moreau à san
francisco un autre à chicago j'étais
invité à boston je voyager en première
classe gt habillé par les grands
couturiers qui prêtait des vêtements et
j'étais logé dans des palaces et
heureusement que j'avais des amis ou
comme invitée à dîner mais je pouvais
sans 1902 l'avion veut plus d'argent non
mais la vie est formidable parce que
j'ai trouvé sur mon chemin où des gens
sont menées à ma rencontre et je n'ai
jamais désespéré il y avait toujours
quelqu'un qui me donnait 100 francs ou
500 balles et
je suis déjà bien travaillé notre film
que vous devez tourner qui s'appelle
anna karamazov voulait tourner à moscou
et à les lignes grade ce que vous comme
beaucoup d'acteurs de votre génération
vous avez été tenté à un moment parle
par le communisme jamais
je n'ai aucune idéologie vais jamais cru
mais non notre papa qui vous avez donnés
cette éducation qui vous avez dit vous
méfier ou pas du tout pas du tout c'est
peut-être justement mon père était
restaurateur il avait un café c'est con
à force d'entendre les conversations de
bistrot des bistrots que non jamais
effleuré par favre non c'est d'avoir un
cette crainte est à l'époque quand vous
voyez je sais pas il montand signoret
qui partait en urss
ça vous tue pas vous les trouviez
ridicule vous aviez envie de leur dire
de pas y aller non non non puisque je
suis pas militante
d'ailleurs pendant très longtemps j'ai
eu un sentiment de culpabilité de ne pas
en être aussi tranchée de ne pas d'avoir
des avis sur tout et puis le privilège
de l'âge c'est que maintenant je peux
dire franchement ouvertement que ninon
l'histoire de lomé raison en quelque
sorte oui est ce que vous pensez
puisqu'on en parle régulièrement dans la
presse
est-ce que vous pensez que la monarchie
représente un avenir pour ces pays là
quand on voit le roi de roumanie qui
essayent de revenir le roi de bulgarie
le roi de yougoslavie le grand duc qui
va à leningrad
je crois que c'est un ami on vous prend
et raccorder les séquelles des scories
qui traînent dans la tête des gens et la
connaissance que chez tout le monde sait
que rien ne recommençons dit je ne pense
pas dans ma vie avoir aimé un homme a
non non c'est pas grave du tout un bon
et je le reconnais je hier la plupart
des gens sont comme moi on est amoureux
on est passionnément attaché
on repousse il ya la main mais l'amour
l'alliance ce que j'appelle l'alliance
c'est à dire un échange profond à des
intéressés un amour absolu
je n'ai pas connu en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas connu vous regrettez oui
quelque part j'espère le connaître avant
de mourir oui et peut-être que ça ne
sera pas sous la forme que tout le monde
peut imaginer
et
[Musique]
quand vous étiez petit il vous aider
réellement voulu être religieuse oui je
devais avoir 5 ans j'étais frappé par le
rituel égalité d'humeur
c'est à dire que dans la vie à la maison
c'était plutôt en dents de scie j'aimais
la musique j'aimais l'ordonance voilà
j'aime beaucoup la rigueur quand vous
dites j'ai un maître intérieur de qui
s'agit-il
je veux dire qu'à partir du moment où on
n'est pas perméable comme une éponge et
où on ne se laisse pas influencer par
tout ce qui nous entoure et qu'on ne vit
pas que par rapport au regard des autres
au jugement des autres
cette voie là s'expriment vous avez
toujours préféré le terme sensualité et
sexualité tout est un peu anti sexualité
au fond - dont on parle et non parce que
je laisse ça aux rapports des corps et
une dimension
une dimension divine j'ai trop de
respect pour tout individu tout être
humain
à commencer par moi pour considérer que
le corps est un morceau de viande est
quelque chose qui se défait qui qui
pourrit et le rapport et la jouissance
ce rapport d'essence et la jouissance
donne une idée plus précise de l'ex task
simplement un orgasme 1 coûte que comme
disait mon d'analystes qui laisse pas
grand chose
joli du nous sommes autre chose que de
la mouture wii brouillon dieu le terme
croire est un terme profane ça a à voir
avec la crédulité je ne crois que ce que
je vois
j'ai une sensation très exact de quelque
chose de magnifique
nous croyons l'âme l'esprit mais quand
vous dites on vit seul long mur sun la
solitude n'est pas une erreur
épouvantable c'est c'est quelque chose
d'exaltant parce que la solitude ne veut
pas dire être isolé ne veut pas dire
être séparés des autres c'est être avec
les autres et si je suis conscient de ma
solitude je peux encore mieux comprendre
celle des autres et la souffrance de
ceux qui ne la supporte pas bien merci
mme merkel
bien j'accueille maintenant une grande
dame une grande dame rapporte un autre
jeune fille voici mademoiselle mans
à
je m'emploie bonsoir cabinet comme ça et
voilà c'est content de vous avoir avec
nous ce soir jeunes ça me fait vraiment
très plaisir
je suis content de vous aimez pas qu'on
vous appelle madame mot préféré
mademoiselle pas ce que vous dites
madame roux c'est ma mère mais donc vous
c'est plutôt mademoiselle moreau puisque
était marié depuis nanterre voilà alors
cette actrice et chanteuse
vous êtes un médecin chanteuse
d
on sait la mémoire bien mais bien ses
classiques à ces documents de les
connaître
g hassan al bachir donc vous êtes comme
j'ai dit actrice comédienne chanteuse
réalisatrice et maintenant metteur en
scène de théâtre puisque vous monter une
pièce shy aux éventuels casseurs
chaillot s'appelle un trait de l'esprit
qui est écrite par margaret edson vous
avez fait l'adaptation wii et la mise en
scène voilà on va faire un petit peu
c'est comment ces jeunes vivent à
montréal
formidable la grande actrice alors le
pitch de la pièce c'est une divine
béring qui est professeur qui souffre
d'un cancer en phase terminale et vous
dites en ballon de la pièce que c'est un
c'est le triomphe de l'esprit sur la
matière oui c'est à dire que c'est un
raccourci saisissant
c'est une pièce qui dure 90 minutes mais
on peut se dire qu'en venant au monde
nous avons tous un virus qui va nous
mener le temps qu'il faut peut-être 80
90 40 ça dépend jusqu'à la mort et cette
femme qui a étudié la poésie un poète
extraordinaire qui s'appelle john donne
dont la vie a été très mouvementée qui a
commencé à être aimé des femmes et à
aimer les femmes et puis petit à petit
la progresser vers la lumière
j'appellerais ça comme ça et qui lui a
appris le courage la lucidité et elle
fait ce chemin avec beaucoup de lucidité
d'humour et elle fait rire
il ya des gens que ça a beaucoup choqué
parce qu'ils croient que quand on
souffre on pleure tout le temps mais la
vie c'est un mélange moi il m'est arrivé
de rire comme une folle à l'enterrement
de mon père mais ça veut pas dire que je
n'étais pas triste alors l'actrice qui
joue le rôle principal celui là michael
en fait je vis été contacté pour le rôle
principal
vous pensez que ce rôle doit être tenu
par quelqu'un qui est encore en âge
d'avoir des enfants
oui et donc comme ça n'est pas mon cas
j'ai tout de suite proposé d'en faire la
mise en scène j'en ai envie tout de
suite j'ai des mauvais souvenirs quand
vous avez voulu avoir des enfants à une
pierre cardin en 62 noms barney on n'a
pas pu alors qu'avant je tomber enceinte
pour un oui pour un non
et là j'ai pensé qu'il y avait un
problème et puis j'ai fait faire des
examens et à ce moment là on a on a vu
que
jamais un cancer et on a intérêt à bien
le père est apparemment mais oui jamais
eu de séquelles avenir compliqué mais
alors tout ça m'amène à parler de vous a
parlé de votre de votre oeuvre
on peut dire votre vie votre oeuvre la
légion d'honneur
pourquoi vous la mettez un parce que mon
père serait drôlement et 10 rebonds
votre père était anglaise parce qu'on
parlait parlait tout à l'air de donne du
poète john et vous l'avez lu très jeunes
6e voilà votre mère était anglaise elle
est venue à paris pour danser aux folies
bergères vote mais a été danseuse
c'est incroyable ça et puis elle a
rencontré votre votre père s'appelait
paul moreau qui avait monté un
restaurant à montmartin l'euro pour les
mots marc 3 mai soirée non c'est un
atoll désiré mans a signé comme son père
s'appelait recel ouais j'avais les jolis
prénoms dans la famille donc il vient il
montre un restaurant à montmartre et
montrent un restaurant à montmartre quoi
vous venez souper les artistes vient la
jauge georges voilà et votre mère s'est
retrouvée enceinte
et alors elle abandonne la dance kids
assez triste quand même mal abandonne la
danse et finalement la rue toute sa vie
des regrets de ne pas avoir été artiste
non oui elle ne pas aller toujours du
voyage en amérique qu'elle aurait dû
faire
mais elle me l'a dit assez tardivement
quand même mais j'ai senti que j'étais
pas vraiment désiré mais après quand je
lui ai dit ce que je voulais faire
alors là elle m'a vraiment encore rêver
oui vous dit chez nous il s'était plaint
de dureté de chagrin pourquoi parce que
c'était c'était dur la vie était dure
mon père vient d'une famille paysanne
moi je suis une enfant du 19e siècle en
fait voyager telle mais avec ce principe
j'avais pas le droit de lire les
journaux
je n'avais pas le droit de lui
vous lisiez sous les draps avec un temps
de trajet oui on a fait venir un médecin
parce que j'avais les yeux cernés passe
comme si ce n'est de masturbation mais
c'était la lecture on parlait pas
beaucoup de sexualité chez vous c'est
être et le recrutement bah c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient des sous-entendus tout le
temps pour le café tout ça et alors on
disait attendait veux-tu sortir s'il te
plaît naturellement je m'étais derrière
la porte pour essayer d'en temps mais je
n'avais pas besoin de ça parce que dans
les libres et ça les gens qui n'aiment
pas lire ça devrait les encourager c'est
là que j'ai tout appris s'est expliqué
très très bien je à l'élite pendant
graphique un des livres le bruit des
lacets la culotte qui tombent les
frémissements les battements du coeur
toute l'émotion lui qui lui saute dessus
dans une calèche si magnifique
alors si vous étiez exposé quand même à
tous les dangers auxquels sont exposés
les enfants et un boulanger à côté de
chez vous ça c'est un meurtre à
montmartre que tu es très pervers un
presque accrochant ouest un cochon il
s'est toujours vous toucher et vous
quand vous allez voir votre peur disait
mais toi tu es une [ __ ] t'as l'esprit
mal tourné
oui me disait que j'étais précieuse que
j'étais une salade mais parce que c'est
une solidarité masculine qui existe sans
doute mois maintenant alors moment fait
un quartier très chaud à l'époque on
vendait de l'alcool le sexe maintenance
ou simple quand même remarque pour
maintenant oui mais moi n'oubliez pas
que j'ai connus montmartre au moment de
l'adolescence au moment de l'occupation
allemande
alors j'ai vu des trucs absolument
dégueulasse interdit aux [ __ ] interdit
aux juifs
j'ai vu des gens se vendre pour 1 kilo
de beurre et
mais vraiment des gens qui faisaient
n'importe quoi pour gagner du pognon et
d'autres pour se nourrir
alors quand vous connaissez pas grand
chose de la vie enfin que vous attendez
à la découvrir
vous dites que les adultes c'est moi non
pas vous découvrez le théâtre wallon
voir mary bale la comédie française
pierre antigone d'abord antigone ruki
dans le hall avec mme nelles valentin ah
bon vous ignorez tout sauf quand je
connais mary bale n'est pas la seule à
son nom sur un pull antigone la
résistance sahraouie
je ris et puy mary bale dans phèdre la
passion amoureuse pour son gendre ça ça
me faisait remarquer ce sens est
décisive pour votre location ça mais là
vous avez dit je vais être comédienne
ouais et on vous avez de la chance parce
que vous avez eue 2010 n'est ce qu'était
le loyer la colonie française comme prof
comme beaucoup de chance un titre très
très sévères j'avais demandé plus sévère
puisque mon père athée contre alors je
voulais vraiment être sûr que je pouvais
tenir le coup et lui il a été pas tant
parce que comme j'avais pas dessous il
m'a fait de travailler pour rien et il
m'a préparé vous a préparé au
conservatoire gratuitement et car il
votre père quand il a vu ça qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait quand il a vu autant de
critères nuage était déjà actrice il
anima photo en première page de france
soir ah ouais votre mère était retourné
en angleterre avec votre petite soeur
vous étiez resté avec votre père qui
d'ailleurs à part des espoirs puis
coller un peu trop et le jour il a vu la
photo que vous avez viré a coûté au cul
ouais c'est pas rigolo mais ça rigolait
pas du tout alors à priver vous voir la
main de temps en temps théâtre
ben oui mais il était aux 1er 2e rei
dormait alors les acteurs qui à l'ère
bouddhiste 10 mrd un titre
à ce qu'elle disait bien que j'étais mon
père il dort même avant de dormir il
disait c'est ma fille c'est je ne sais
pas qui dorment ils sont tous et qui
ronflait quoi hein
et alors quand ils voyaient jeanne faire
des films il disait tout s embrasser par
gadin ce vieux dégueulasse tomber ça
pour ça pour être ton père mais vous
savez qu'on en parle malin mais je
n'adore way de votre père ben oui mais
m'a servi vous avez des mots coupés mais
oui bah oui parce que moi vous êtes
rebeller contre quelque chose de laid
quelque chose contre moi très bel été
très beau c'est la prochaine fois je
m'entends il voudrait lui vous tenez lui
c'est pas la bouche 7 qui n'est ni bon
c'est une bouche extraterrestres et la
voix ah non deux qui s'annonce très bon
alors on va parler des autres hommes de
valdi puisqu'on va faire la soirée sur
votre père quand même
voilà les zones de la vie de jeanne
moreau a déjà eu des as je mélange tout
moi j'ai un jour vous découvrez que vous
êtes enceinte votre premier amour qui
s'appelait jean louis richard à vous
aviez 20 ans et vous vous preniez la
grossesse communes comme une punition
dans la grossesse gelé très bien vécu
mais après c'est l'idée d'avoir un bébé
vous plaisait pas je n'ai pas envie
donc j'étais là en suisse vous faire
avorter et vous n'allez pas fait c'est
dit retard c'était trop tard alors droit
entrée en lice mais si vous dépassez le
séjourna oui
et lorsque très disert si vous partez en
suisse et vous revenez à paris que vous
tombez dans le métro complètement par
hasard sur le père de l'enfant
malin jean lever les charges année père
didier et qu'est ce qu'il a fait nous
emmener dans sa famille oui ou fera-t-il
copine elle a des problèmes elle sait
pas où loger à bon très bien et puis je
me jeu via mois deux mois et on se
disait on chuchotait on dormait dans la
bibliothèque
comment on va faire pour leur annoncer
j écoute on va acheter de la laine de
layette des aiguilles à tricoter vivait
commencé à tricoter puis je vais laisser
traîner ça ils vont comprendre
ouais c'était le fou rire c'est ce qui
s'est passé et c'est vrai que j'ai
accouché la veille de votre mariage à
cette fort non le lendemain le lendemain
au lendemain du mariage enfants plus
fort
non j'étais au cinéma la belle vous
n'étiez pas très attendri par là par la
naissance de votre enfant parce que vous
téléphoner aussitôt à votre metteur en
scène jean marc st pierre mais vous le
dis ce que je devrais de travailler dans
dix jours
j'ai mis deux heures à accoucher oui oui
j'ai téléphoné à 6h merveille on sait
jamais quoi dire aux gens qu'on a envie
de réveiller un 6 heures du matin c'est
pas mal quand même
ça y est j'ai un fils les a couchés
under vous avez jamais été une mère très
attentionné quand même maintenant je le
suis en fait ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé c'est que quand votre fils a
eu son accident de voiture avec belmondo
un jour c'était le tournage de quel film
moderato voilà et donc belmondo prend
une dauphine gordini keitel à la vôtre
que je ne conduisais pas tout mais avait
lui là mais son père n'était région il
embarque jérôme donc le fils de jeanne
ils ont l'accident il passait ce jour
dit sayawama et là vous commencez quand
même à vous dire à vous intéresser un
peu plus à l'union mais j'ai toujours
aimé tendrement non j'essaie de vous
faire passer pour un couperet j'étais
faire de vous un portrait le portrait
d'un monde mais comme je l'étais aux
estivants mais maintenant il va très
bien il faut dire les choses il vit en
californie sein d'accor donc vous n'avez
pas été une mère très attentionné vous
êtes une grande amoureuse quand même et
vous avez connu beaucoup d'hommes orson
welles
c'est vrai qu'ils voulaient que vous
quittiez tout pour le suivent en
amérique c'est pas vrai
non c'est pas vrai quel beau worth et or
ce mardi jean après il m'a dit j'étais
amoureux fou de toi je n'étais pas
perdre avant et vous l'aviez après oui
et moi on m'a dit qu'il était prêt à
payer le dédit de la comédie française
pour vous le suivirent les plages adouna
oui d'accord mais pour que je couche
avec trouvé d'accord vous n'avez pas osé
vous dire que j'étais amoureux de vous
après non après bien après vous avez ces
trois films avec lui oui c'est elle
stoppe le procès plein procès et piste
henri martin voilà c'est ça donc après
louis malle les amants initialement
imaginé que d'un document de mont louis
mame oui un d un démo mais vous auriez
jamais fait les hameaux comme ça si vous
aviez pas de l'ensemble ça se sent votre
voile finement peut-être jet vous sentir
en faisant le film que ça allait vers la
fin que le fait de faire ce film est
bien sûr un bien sûr je sentais que je
voudrais passer quelque chose et que
je jouais en accélérer la fin de notre
de notre relation se brûler votre
relation avec lui dans ce film oui vous
avez tourné avec brigitte bardot s'est
pas très bien passé non s'il entendra
moi ce qu'on l'a raconté je vous assure
que ça s'est très très bien
je ne veux pas vous contredire va
jusqu'au futur
brigitte est quelqu'un de magnifique et
qui n'a jamais aimé être comédienne ça
la barbe
donc elle n'est pas à l'heure elle râle
énerve 1 c'est tout
j'ai pas là d une panne de courant si
c'est vrai il ya une panne de courant
sur le tournage de de viva maria donc
les petites femmes de paris et l'a dit
si on trouve jamais assassiné ce ne sera
pas la peine de chercher bien loin la
salsa ou henin n'a dit comme ça mais
c'est bien sûr après du truffaut il a
réparé elle c'est une aventure exclu
faux nom une amitié amour l amitié
amoureuse avant karbaoui maintient
l'écart grâce et c'est mademoiselle
chanel qui vous a dit un jour j'ai pas
le temps de m'occuper de toi
ouais vous citez moi le film avec l'osé
va il m'a dit allez voir ce jeune est
qu'il fait des très beaux vêtements et
j'ai vu vraiment justes ont défait le
petit curieux dans tout le monde parle
et ça a duré quatre ans quoi un mois ça
va plus le pierre cardin jamais dire
ouais tout le monde quoi je m'appelle
pierre cardin
alors après il ya eu le bouquet alors là
c'est le bouquet c'est le réalisateur de
l'exorciste et de french connection
william friedkin alors lui quand je lui
demandais je vous demande pourquoi vous
l'avait épousée vous dites c'est le seul
qui me demandait en mariage que vous
étiez bouleversé ah oui ça m'a ému
si dans une boîte de nuit à new york
ouais il vous est demandé en mariage je
n'ai pas pu a craqué j'ai dit oui ça m'a
paru bien là le problème c'est que vous
ne dirigez votre carrière quoi
maintenant à partir du moment où le maïs
vous est ce que j'étais malade friedkin
oui madame prix de keynes était sa maman
alors il a commencé à bloquer mon
imprésario et l'a dit non non ils
disaient tous les scénarios
moi on me les donnaient même pas lire et
ils disaient ah non madame friedkin ne
tourne pas sale madame prix de qui ne
tourne pas avec match
madame prime keane alors j'ai dit bon
vous avez divorce et c'est à vous que
divorce accusés du pognon oui cela m'a
croyable ça c'est une époque je n'ai pas
beaucoup d'argent ça ok aucun soin j'ai
une époque assez bizarre parce que vous
passiez de festival en festival
vous avez ce n'est pas qu'on a commencé
à me rendre des hommages alors jamais
des garde-robes somptueux et très bon
bagage je voyageais en première d'un
hôtel sublim et puis si je voulais faire
une course et prend un taxi je n'ai pas
de quoi vous habitez ou j'ai éclaté
alors lui avait un appartement vide
j'habitais chez lui
j'ai une autre amie qui ma loge et
francine racette donald sutherland l'ag
à cause des impôts tout ça à cause emery
est plus arrondie var alors ça coûte
cher mais tant qu'on divorce moi pas de
coûter cher ajoute bien le jury des
villes irakiennes au géant votre cas si
vous dites jeanne vous dites j'ai eu
beaucoup même dans ma vie mais je pense
pas avoir aimé un homme non jédir aînés
et mais je pense l'amour l'amour parfait
l'amour magnifique l'amour sans sans
intérêt l'amour amour absolu l'amour
absolu je t'aime mais tu veux être loin
de moi parce que tu ai plusieurs
plus heureuse sans moi très bien ce qui
compte c'est que tu sois heureuse mais
heureux
alors
vous savez les jeunes cons
pas pendant le jingle ah oui là arrivent
à non allez vous allez voir en ébauche
trading
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non il est lent et une rallonge et bien
alors ça s'appelle l'interview alerte
euros c'est tombé sur vos aïeux quelle
est votre première pensée jeunes moreau
lorsque vous trouvez qu'un homme est
séduisant salut jeunes
[Rires]
ça va trois langues à nous engager
est ce que vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer égaient les embrasser vous
faire embrasser invité les trains en
même temps caressé ou vous faire
caresser pareil de larguer ou faire
larguer la renier la guerre les boules a
calé alors quel est pour vous le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte l'été à l'ombre
l'hiver au chaud
quel est le lieu où vous seriez
incapable de faire l'amour le space
mountain près d'une poubelle à près
d'une poubelle
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour
aimer ça dépend des relations
des fois ça commence ça peut commencer
par le sexe et tenir de l'amour oui oui
d'accord et je vous préférez attention
c'est très grave mais un mec qui bosse
bien mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
nina mignotte ah bon je cherche un
troisième à huy des fidèles
[Applaudissements]
alors au sujet si vous êtes à vue le
père est ce que vous préférez pas savoir
où tout ce n'est la pas d'adultère
savons que c'est un mot à l'ensemble du
19e si on sait que ce fut même une
liaison préfère le mot liaison non ça va
ça vient tous abondamment oui tu te
souviens donc voilà donc on n'en parle
même pas on en parle c'est pas n'existe
pas mais on a dû lutter c'est un tel
cliché il ya deux ans qu'ils foutent
leur relation à l'herbe pour ça ça vaut
pas la volonté un nouveau mot pour ça je
sais pas on ne passe pas par la réponse
est ce que vous conservez dernière
question un fantasme non réalisée mi
d'état ah oui vous pensez les réaliser
non seulement ça va pas et vous pensez
que l'épandage aucun procès que c'est
plus excitant de paris
une fois que c'est fait c'est fait
comment ça va très bien vous écrivez
votre biographie actuellement oui alors
comment ça se passe ça fait pas mal de
temps que ça dure l'éditeur s'impatiente
oui ouais faisait du mal un oui à
raconter des trucs mais je vais pas de
votre papa en bas bien sûr génial où est
le père de jeanne s'il avait la closed
doors oui en cultivant la cloche d'or
ouais la main cdh de voilà est la maman
de jeanne était danseuse aux folies
bergères c'est une anglaise indians
voilà vous avez parlé de tout ça ah ben
bien sien ce génial et enfin 50
ouais vous séparer de votre mariage
aussi des tous les six gravement en cinq
jours du mariage à baimbridge alcoa
hollande a le plus le lendemain je vais
t'emmener tout truffaut louis malle
orson welles luis bunuel tout ça oui ben
je vois si j'oublie quelqu'un je
pourrais m'adresser à vous vous allez
parler de william friedkin
bien sûr c'est le seul qui vous ai
jamais demandé en mariage sa vous l'avez
d'épouser finalement emplettes oui ma
foi et cardin faisait pas être cardan
aussi oui mais si génial ce soir
consistoire là en 2005
en 2005 vous viendrait ici un vrai
je vous adore merci main c'est vrai
alors c'est une idole aujourd'hui un
jeune moreau vraiment vous êtes encensé
par tout le monde est devenu intouchable
en panique
on va voir justement on va vous obliger
à dire du mal de vous à être négative
on va faire l'interview brûlons nos
idoles
renault dans lequel mauvais film avez
vous joué il ya mme saint germain des
prés avec berthomieu voilà on garderait
le fort dans quel film vous trouvez-vous
très mauvaise un film de jacques de
villes dont j'ai oublié le titre qui se
passait dans un bar tu t'étais un seul
décor
le pal stocks le paletot michel de
michel david
quel film avez vous accepté uniquement
pour l'argent jeunes un fight band women
le film de martin ritt qui s'appelait
cinq femmes marquées en français mais j
ai gagné j'ai payé mes impôts j'ai dû me
raser la tête
léger gagner l'amitié de silvana mangano
et j'ai appris l'italien grâce à elle et
je vous ai déjà voté à droite n'y ont
jamais combien d'hommes avaient trompé
pas mal pas mal je vous ai déjà dénoncer
quelqu'un jamais est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles de brigitte bardot non
plus quelques caprices de stars
faites-vous régulièrement je voyage avec
mes enrayer sa gêne personne
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait semblant
de téléphoner pour pas donner d'argent
sdf
est-ce que vous avez déjà appelé une
ambulance pour circuler plus vite dans
pareille anneaux un camion de pompiers
est ce que vous trouvez pas j'aime que
catherine deneuve a beaucoup grossi ces
derniers temps quand même
j'ai pas né la jeune actrice très peu
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déjà refusé de
donner de l'argent à une organisation
humanitaire
oui à quelle franchise vous adore
campagne halte voit comment elle répond
mais il m'a dit tu vois comment elle
réellement franche du collier au moins
ben moi aussi j'ai le produit semble pas
du tout mais qui s'était le plus con
dans la ferme il y avait un concours
[Applaudissements]
bien je mens jamais au regard des mois
bien j'attends s'en sépare tout le monde
vous êtes devenu intouchable et tué une
icône alors aurait perdu interview
brûlons les idoles alors jeune qui
aurait pu vous remplacer dans les rois
maudits
c'est l'arrière l'appui qu'est ce que
vous ne savez pas jouer les jeunes
filles dont quel film vous trouvez-vous
très mauvaise dans un film
1 kg dont le paletot le paltoquet
d'accord au casting de quel film avez
vous été refusée un film avec rené clair
la beauté du diable
ils ont pris qu'il ya la place j'ai
oublié son nom 90 non parce qu'après la
part et d'autre 20 l intéressait pas
non mais c'est vrai quel homme à
repousser vos avances bon j'en connais
pas au relais
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai appris un truc je savais pas
c'est j'en connaissais beaucoup et puis
pas des moindres mais je savais par
rejet de ligne et ses énormes au génie
mais je trouve ça formidable ce complice
roger meece j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour lui et un jour vous êtes dans le
bureau de roger nimier je sais plus qui
vient le bureau et ils vous planquer
sous le bureau pendant que son invité la
garonne la loire et je grimpais par la
fenêtre je n'entrais pas par la russie
en tout cas du podium tu vas là et il a
voulu faire une surprise et j'étais sous
la table voilà pendant leur conversation
roger nimier pour quelles raisons vous
êtes ont quitté généralement mal sa part
est prétentieux mais dès que je sentais
la fav nir éventuel je partais
quel est votre pire du faux
l'impatience l'autorité qu'on supporte
mal j'ai une femme et
l'autonomie sur glace marine
indépendance ouais ouais j'ai eu recours
à la chirurgie esthétique
une fois oui pour faire quoi un lifting
comme ça est ce que fait des caprices de
stars n'ont jamais à non j'aime trop
être à l'heure g une discipline de fer
qu'on m'a prise très très jeune j'y
tiens beaucoup sinon je craque
bon je ne peux pas les religieuses et
puis pour l'épater l'air était la
comédie française je suis à bonne école
sacré remercie tous les leaders l'onu
paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]